[Music]
hey everybody welcome to awesome comics
your one-stop shop for everything comic
book entertainment related I am your
host heather ruse I clearly got in this
chair right now because I've killed
Walter he's not here
we took him on yeah sorry about that
everyone I'm just kidding Walter's fine
and well um in fact you can find him on
our Facebook page at facebook.com slash
awesome comic show he did the Thursday
Facebook exclusive video this week
talking all about the new trailer for
Logan the well yeah the new Wolverine
movie that's coming out so if you have
not already checked that out like their
page go ahead facebook.com slash awesome
comics show this week we are talking
about something that you guys have been
asking me about for a while we see in
comments people ask hey do any of you
watch anime or read manga we do so this
time we're focusing just on our favorite
animes and some of the mangas that are
associated with that so that is our Pick
of the Week
going on right now many of the mangas
that we talked about while we're talking
about our favorite animes our Pick of
the Week we got a great panel with us
today so let's get started with the
usual Thank You Sailor Moon
yeah and I'm you can't see what I'm
wearing my Luna tights so that was like
the series that really got me into anime
started me on it like I still have my
old VHS I don't get it yeah hi Trevor
Muller how's it going it's going great
we're all excited I think hopefully I'm
just some guy that just wandered into
the studio hey I'll talk about of me
know I'm Malcolm I'm frequently on the
nostalgia critic and I like anime a
whole lot so I wanted to join in on this
panel and talk about it with you guys
awesome we're excited to have you on the
show finally yeah and this guy decided
to come back to you after a long absence
what's uh
we'll accept you can't be more kawaii
than me okay anime or animate that all
right let's hop right into it let's
start it with Malcolm since you're new
yes what's your favorite anime my
favorite anime is yu yu hakusho wrong I
mean like technically like nostalgic
like speaking from a Stalinist
perspective nostalgia Dragon Ball Z is
up there but I don't want to talk about
Dragon Ball Z I want to talk about an
anime that was inspired by Dragon Ball Z
in my opinion it's called Yu Yu Hakusho
and it's basically about this young guy
in high school he's a delinquent he you
know it's just kind of like meandering
through life trying to you know discover
himself and one day you know he just
ends up getting killed like he runs out
into the street trying to save a boy
from getting hit by a car and he takes
the hit and he's dead like that's how
the series starts out no no it it picks
up from there he ends up in the
spiritual world he ends up being a ghost
and he's just like floating around he's
like I you know our ghost and he runs
into the Grim Reaper who is a beautiful
blue haired bomb anime you know go yeah
yeah and she like guides him to the
afterlife and as it turns out he has
very very unique abilities when it comes
to the spiritual metaphysical world and
they decide to make him a spirit
detective where he goes on missions kind
of you know solving crime and you know
fighting off demons shamans
and other metaphysical beings that are
involved with the spiritual realm and as
a lot of Shonen anime go you know he
ends up you know befriended some of his
enemies and you know picking up more
comrades along the way and it's like a
journey of self-discovery you know
figuring out what it is there's a lot of
martial arts and elements involved with
it and I really like this anime I'm not
too fond of how it ends without spoiling
it like you guys try to avoid spoilers
right I don't know like for you guys
thanks maybe I don't want to spoil it
you should have seen it before I know
I've seen it okay so I'm gonna do it do
it I'm gonna spoil it spoilers you know
there's a twist like with the the
titular hero they end up like finding
out something about themselves you know
that's been pressing all along and just
like oh that's why they're so good at it
I hate it when they do that like it
turns out that he's part demon and
that's why he's so you know perceptive
to the spiritual realm and I'm just like
Oh why'd you do that it's like why does
he have to be part demon why can't just
be you know like really good at you know
it's still really good it's just up
until that point it's just kind of like
mmm doesn't have to be party and in back
of my mind my head candy whose snack
party you showed me a few episodes it's
kind of an older school anime to like
it's like yeah yeah anime yeah like
right at the like peak of Dragonball
like GT was just like in full swing
mm-hmm you know talk about GT
[Music]
one of those eighties like mad cross
Robotech sound a mr. right like these
weird laser sound did have a run on
Cartoon Network as well so I know that's
how I watched it yeah I'm not gonna lie
to you I'm sorry I did I watched it on
Cartoon Network
you are not true you know the funny
thing is we I think all did the same
thing which we another picking ones a
little outside of the box because we
don't get the same I it isn't my I would
say top five or top ten but I went with
paranoia agent okay which was directed
by Satoshi cone rest in peace he's no
longer with us but in my opinion one of
the great anime directors and it had me
hooked at like the first episode it's
basically about this cartoonist who
creates this character minami-chan and
it's like this typical Japanese little
adorable cute thing that has these
soulless dog's eyes that just like burn
a hole through your soul and it becomes
this big hit and she's looking to create
like a new character and at the same
time this character called in the
original was called showman buck doll
but they translated the English to a
little Slugger I would have gone with
the boy bat or bat boy just because the
tabloids but this kind of sort of
mythical character comes out and it's
like is this a creation of her own
psyche is this a real character you know
it keeps twisting in on itself and all
of his like films do that it's what is
real what is reality you know there's a
whole lot of dream sequences and
one thing that runs through all of his
stuff is the characters are always
mentally just on the edge
they are like disturbed they question
reality you never know what reality is
and so it's about this character they're
trying to catch that basically bashes
people on the head yeah and seems to
provide them with some sort of mental
release it was like they were asking for
this and it's two detectives a young
like impressionistic like kind of naive
happy guy and then the older one Akari
who just is like the grumpy old cynic
and it Kari maybe one of my favorite
characters in any anime because he's the
only one with all this craziness going
around him who kind of rejects the
insanity and is like no you know we we
gotta you know face reality and you know
make it through all the way to the end
and I I won't give away the ending but
it it goes completely nuts off the rails
but in that rare good way in my opinion
yeah and probably my favorite episode
one of my favorites is there's one about
a suicide Club that's right because one
of the one of the members that joins is
that who they think it is and I won't
spoil that one but that one's just
amazing and there's a running joke about
it it sounds dark and it is but it is
very funnier than you think there's a
good balance yeah and then I'd say the
other one that was that I really enjoyed
was one that's about the making of an
anime anime a making of an anime within
an anime that's all about the production
and how it's going completely off the
rails and then you know a little Slugger
comes in and you know peacefully you
know tries to end it for them but yeah
so I that would be my pick yeah and you
you brought a really good manga too as
well you know as far as I know there was
the paranoia agent manga so I went with
a Nausicaa the wind one of the earliest
Miyazaki works and the movie is very
good it's one of my favorite Studio
Ghibli films but you know it's it's kind
of short even they have a whole lot of
time you only have two hours to flesh
out this story so this is like the Lord
of the Rings special edition version
there's like have you
the exact number was I think there's
seven or eight but comes with awesome
poster work and maps and the leaves cool
the artwork is really uh it's really
integrated thank you
I can I can speak today it's really
intricate for a manga like those
beautiful works amazing and it's like
this the whole way through so yeah manga
pick you should really check it out if
you have not honestly guys I was gonna
bring like some try guns some FMA a few
the little cowboy bebop things they
released in this and this is the one
that I'm just like this is the one I had
to have and it was not a bad guy it's a
great series
[Music]
let's move on to Trevor what's your
favorite anime here I feel like it's in
that the same vein ya know so kind of
like everyone else you know my my pick
this week was really less about my
favorite anime and more my pick of what
made me love anime in the first place so
the the pick that I have is Robotech
right so I'm gonna paint a picture for
you guys real quick
it's 1985 it's one year after a TV show
airs in the United States called
Transformers right I'm four years old
and suddenly a show comes out that
unlike every other show for people my
age is not a 30-minute commercial for
action figures but it should have been
and it is the first space opera that I
ever ended up encountering in the first
TV show I ever encountered where you
have to have seen the previous episodes
to get what was going on and to me
really kind of influenced the type of
stories that I like to tell type of
stories I like to watch you know with
this overarching story around characters
and love and pop culture and war and all
of these elements kind of playing in
with each other now it is streaming on
Netflix right now and
standard-definition so it doesn't look
fantastic unfortunately but I love this
show so much it's a story about an
amateur stunt pilot who gets thrown into
a war when the earth gets invaded by
50-foot tall aliens you know which the
five-year-old and me was just like yes
first of all pilot of all transformers
right the the pilots in the show pilot
jet planes that turn into robots and
that is awesome it is Top Gun and robots
what does not love about this right but
at the same time like there's a love
triangle going on between him and this
pop star and this career military woman
right because it's Japan is the downfall
of the series I will say she is the low
point right I feel so terrible for the
the actress who had to voice her because
she's heard that her entire career
it's like window Lloyd
poor guy he's like no I didn't ruin Star
Wars but no so you know but it
essentially follows Rick hunter right
and his his life in his career through
this war and the things that he has to
go through to try to create peace in a
culture where we have music and art and
all these things against an alien race
that has been bred and only knows war
and that is all they understand and they
are trying to spy on our culture and
subvert our culture and do other things
and eventually get seduced by our
culture and start to realize that there
is something beyond war and something
beyond you know what they've thought to
live their entire life it's very adult
in a way that the genre at least
nowadays isn't always right this is so
old and so light years ahead of its time
you know that storyteller and you look
at the types of shows that were coming
out
in 85 right where it's episode 2 episode
it follows a very set formula good guys
versus bad guys here those lines blur
and they have entire episodes here where
characters actually sit out the fighting
you know Fighting's happening you can
hear it in the background but they'll
have an entire episode just dedicated to
character and Ozzie as a four year leg
as a four year old kid right like I've
never seen anything like that before and
suddenly you get invested in these
characters in a way that you don't get
with a regular Saturday morning cartoons
you know that's something that kids in
particular because they can relate to
that because often kids are the ones
sitting out when the bad stuff goes down
so I thought those those episodes you
know I watched Matt cross more as an
adult but those episodes tapped into
something very like pre Mario from my
child of mine when a disaster was
happening or when Bad's like when bad
weather would strike you know you're
sitting there just kind of on the
sidelines it's like well I hope
everything works out for the best in the
final point that I'll make too because
this was probably the first time I had
seen this and this kind of is the
opposite of what you were talking about
with your show Malcolm the main
characters not the best character in
this show he's not the best pilot he's
not the best fighter he doesn't even
like war and in fact he gets shot
which to me makes him way more relatable
than some invincible character on a
battlefield that character exists in the
show right like you know and ends up
meeting their match in their rival on
the enemy's side and of course the the
battle that they have almost becomes
like a dance and the to spawn romance
through fighting like it's just this
incredible mr. again of love and music
and pop culture in a way that I've never
seen anything like it and all the
spiritual successors to the show since
them have successfully tried to
incorporate in C which lasts you child
right now right like if you want to
watch all 86 episodes like do it keep in
mind again I'm a totally be wearing
nostalgia goggles when I look at this
show but I'm okay with that
Ayana all right well assuming that
everyone else is coming with Cowboy
Bebop and Drago I went ahead and went
with Sol which is also an amazing Shonen
anime show now it's lead is actually a
female maca and so that's kind of like
not the usual because it's usually like
male leads and kids but it does follow
these students at the death weapon
Meister Academy so you can either be a
Meister or a weapon the Meister yields
the weapons and they're humans but the
weapon can transform themselves into a
weapon to be wielded and it's awesome
and they go hunt these eva location
souls and they'll kill these quetions
and then eat the souls and you have to
eat 99 Souls and then a soul of a witch
and then you can actually be wielded as
death lord death scythe and Lord death
is super annoying in this whole thing
where they talk about how he used to be
this terrible guy and now he wears like
a mask and talks and that's funny boy to
like you know cuz now he's running a
death Academy he has to be approachable
to kids
with funny voice over top of that not
the most annoying though the most
annoying weird long no is he human I
don't actually know what here's like
clown bitty collar thing and then has
like this weird mask
I don't know it's like a weird like like
old style like I don't know Timmy masks
or whatever he's like really tiny and
then he transforms into a sword
Excalibur obviously and he's like the
best the best weapon ever but he's super
powerful and will make you be able to do
all these things but he's so none of the
Meister's can like stand to be with him
for long and so it follows these teams
of kids that are at like the top 10% of
their class because there's this whole
depth meister academy that we're at and
so there's like maybe about like eight
main people that we follow their story
and it's nice because they kind of each
weapon and wheels are a team there are
sort of opposite genders so there's maka
and soul eater are the main ones that we
follow and then there's death the kid
which is Lord deaths son and he actually
has two weapons Patty and Liz Liz and
Patty and their guns that he like holds
by the pinkie and like their
sisters me and my sister talked about
cosplaying them football but I need to
come back kid death is like super super
super like OCD so he likes everything to
be even and he'll stop mid-battle
to be like and just stop so this is one
of those shows that really really like
has these moments of like violence and
super darkness and super poignant
moments and then all of a sudden they
just like break it with comedy and
brevity like all of a sudden so it's a
really really really fun thing to watch
because of the pace of it is really it
keeps you on your toes and stuff also
has a great theme song that's been
there's some cool like character names
in it that you'll recognize like there's
a doctor stunned there's a Blaire the
witch the Ripper is a Kishin soul right
so you've got all these like little
names Medusa so it's just a really
really enjoyable watch and you can read
the manga manga however you like to say
it you can go read it it's very similar
some of the weapons are switched what
they actually are but for the most part
it's relatively similar there's very
minor character changes in it yeah so
it's a good read it's a good watch go
check it out cuz I love it Funimation on
YouTube has it I think the first episode
is dubbed but the rest of it is sucked
so it should still be on their youtube I
don't know if they're down get down to
you I don't know about the rights but
there's
I haven't seen if you've seen sullied or
not alright yeah I'm gonna just say
superfast my favourite anime is Mobile
Suit Gundam I'm a huge fan of mecca's
and it basically created the real robot
genre
Trevor's would not exist it's a great
war story space opera type thing again
where it's the earth federal forces
fighting the principality of zeon who
are space people who live in colonies
who have revolted against the rule of
the earth federation it's a great story
check it out
I love it I look to build the little
models as well thanks for coming out
being on the show with us today guys
when we find you on social media Trevor
Trevor a Muller is my twitter my
facebook my YouTube all of it Trevor
a Muller comm find me there I am a
Twitter here Facebook you know Rob
Facebook
Robert walk around my profile has me in
a fedora and I'm going like Twitter at
Malcolm the REA awesome alright and you
can find me on Twitter at Heather verse
or Instagram at a shrimps so for all
these guys here we will see you on the
next page
[Music]
[Applause]